hallo leute wie sieht eure mal wann und
wie kommen zu einem neuen koch wie und
heute machen wir ein drei-gänge-menü
aber nicht mit lebensmitteln sondern mit
knete
ja wenn ich das jetzt gerade dass dieses
videos nicht sponsert und zu recht fragt
ihr euch jetzt wenn es aber warum geht
es um drei gänge menü das ist so dass
ich in letzter zeit mir immer mal wieder
videos angeschaut habt von so leuten auf
youtube die mit fimo zum beispiel kleine
lebensmittel machen und dann bin ich
letztens gestern auf dem video gestoßen
von so japanischen plastik essen also
wie japanisches plastik essen
hergestellt wird und warum sie in japan
so viel plastik essen vor den
restaurants entstehen
die erklärung ist gar nicht so
kompliziert ist die teilt appetitlicher
aus wendt vor deinem restaurants und
plastikteller steht wo halt das essen
schon angezeigt wird das machen sie
schon ewig ich weiß nicht warum dieser
trend sich nicht im westen irgendwie
verbreitet hat wahrscheinlich weil man
auch einfach fotos machen kann von denen
essen aber jahren haben sie diese kunst
so verfeinert dass du echt glaubst dass
dieses essen echtes früher wurde es zwar
aus wachs gemacht und heute aus plastik
das haben wir halt leider nicht zur
verfügung deshalb dachte ich kniete ist
die beste alternative ich habe auch ein
bisschen figur aber viel mehr so kleinen
würde gerne wirklich so große portionen
machen also mein ziel ist es dass es so
realistisch wie möglich aussieht und er
sich ist vor mein restaurant stellen
kann und welche sich noch nicht habe
aber das kommt schon bald und wer meint
eine kitchen drei-gänge-menü gesehen hat
weiß es ich einfach die besten drei
gänge menüs der welt herstellen kann
also lasst uns lustig ich muss ehrlich
sein ich bin noch nicht ganz sicher was
ich machen möchte und wird
daneben weil ich ganz süß schauen 2018
habe ich bin dann auch einmal einen
blick nachdem ihn nämlich 100 mal
geschrieben habe dass es den schauen
soll habe ich ihn jetzt angeschaut und
natürlich ist der mega gut sehr pervers
aber mega gut
roman die kleine vanessa welt so happy
die große wann ist das auch bio das kam
so viel drin kam mir das früher mehr
vorsicht kinder hinter hatte und diese
klein waren und dann wirkt das so groß
ich glaube schon
oder sind die packung kleiner geworden
also wissen ja schon mal sehr
appetitlich farben ein cooles
ich esse 20 paarung knete ich habe auch
eine play doh kitchen creation gefunden
und was ich ganz cool fand waren diese
silikonform weil da kann ich dann ein
bisschen schummeln
falls ich in eine form brauche und
denkst bringt mich hier so können
jugendliche machen und bacon und und
zitronen und brokkoli märchen ich kenne
gemüse und würstchen ein hackebeil
kleider du kannst mich hier an dieser
stelle zu sparen was ich jetzt hier
eigentlich auch schreiben werbe und
wegen marken nennung dass wie bei
instagram ich hoffe nicht ich hoffe wir
dürfen sie noch abends zurück sein klub
kennt halt als kinder wie mir das immer
gewünscht hier macht sie nämlich knete
rein und dann machst du so ich habe ganz
viele quellen die farben gibt eine küche
ich könnte so schima 01 wir sortieren
und geknetet das lied nach essen aus
dass das essen aus
grayson kindheits begriffs der liste
steht ist realistisch dittwar mit und
bittet leicht blau aber sorry ich glaube
wir entscheiden am ende was unser
drei-gänge-menü sein will weil das mit
den toxischen fahren so gut
zusammenpasst fangen wir mit sushi
annika das schön ein
ok dann brauchen wir wohl erst mal rein
es ist aller welt warum hat man als
erwachsener damit auf das ist die größe
von einem mini wir bleiben komplett
asiatisch ich habe schon mein menü vor
augen wir machen lachs drauf lachs ist
nämlich so schön giftig wie dieser
scheiß hier
das ist so richtig toxic orange das ist
so ein mittelding bräuchten eigentlich
das dazwischen wir versuchen zu mischen
das sieht sich greift es witzig
natürlich komme ich ein asiatisches
essen bei japan aus japan kommt muss
japan jetzt wichtig ausschneiden wieso
lachs aus schon ein bisschen kann so
scheiße aus ich liebe es ich bin wieder
[Musik]
schaut euch diese reiskörner ich muss
jeden einzelnen reiskorn mit der hand
niveau da wir haben mich gesagt ist
einfach wird noch lange brauchen bis
katie price
[Musik]
um mein gott ich habe ganz so lange
gebraucht ist sie ist träger schaffe und
jetzt ran summe dass ihr es sharp sieht
[Musik]
als vorspeise gibt es ein klacks
zum hauptgang gibt es gebratene nudeln
mit rockmusik und zum nachtisch gibt es
dieses japanische ding was ich weiß ist
aber sieht lecker aus
ich hoffe natürlich hat diese folgen
gefallen und wenn ihr mehr knet food
sehen wollt vielleicht mache ich es auch
nächste mal mit fimo oder so vielleicht
ein bisschen realistischer und
vielleicht mit einer kamera die auf
meine hände zeitweilig glauben man
konnte ganz vielen nicht so gut sehen
ist aber ein lernprozess hier auf diesem
kanal man muss ja immer sich erweitern
kein stillstand und vanessa kann man
auch mal dafür loben wie toll dieses
aussieht verdammte scheiße das ist doch
super
die muss ich unbedingt mal bei wie
schmeckt's machen das muss ich unbedingt
noch tun
ja ich muss so vieles machen bis dann